welcome everybody to this session on
human AI collaboration for decision
making my name is Desmond anusha and I'm
a researcher in the adaptive systems and
interaction group here at Microsoft
Research AI today I will be Co chairing
this session together with Ajay Kumar
who is also a researcher in the same
group so the focus of this faculty
summit has been the future of work and
of course AI technologies are starting
to become important parts of our
everyday work and however we would like
human AI collaboration to become sleep
seamless and fluent but as many of the
people in the room here know
collaboration is not easy this is not a
modular process where you put the two
parts together and hope that it will
magically work instead there are many
aspects of collaboration that need to be
planned and optimized carefully
beforehand either in the human and AI
interaction or in the very foundation of
the algorithms themselves today we have
an amazing line of speakers that have
worked on collaboration in different
aspects of it either in the physical
world or in human AI decision-making or
from algorithmic transparency and
interpretability
and the first speaker that I'd like to
introduce is IANA Howard ini is a Linda
and Mark Smith professor at Georgia Tech
University and the chair of the school
of interactive computing where she leads
the lab on human and automation systems
her area of research is really centered
around the concept of humanized
intelligence which in her own words is
the process of embedding human cognitive
capabilities into the control path of
autonomous systems please welcome Anna
[Applause]
all right so what I'm gonna do in this
twenty five minutes that I have with you
is really introduce you into the world
of experimentalists and so I am an
experimentalist what that means is that
I look at robotic systems intelligent
autonomous system so not necessarily
Wizard of Oz system so real systems that
have intelligence that interact with
individuals in the real world
and when I say individuals its real
people not like labs and students but
it's actually individuals that you don't
necessarily have a model of and you try
to and so what I want to talk to you is
really about the role of these systems
when they're interacting with people and
the positive things that our systems can
provide also some of the concerns as
well as some of the bad that I see and
so I'd like to start off with the good
motivated by some of the work that I do
I look at with respect to the good of
this collaboration I look at how do we
use robots and AI technologies to engage
children with special needs in therapy
and educational opportunities and so
that's really the purvey of all the
things that I think about when designing
systems and so one of the nice things
about working with kids is guarantee the
kids are not your researchers and so
everything that we do and think about
has to apply to this large demographic
of individuals that we have to think
about modeling and have this iteration
with and one of the things that I try to
motivate people with at the start even
though there's a large demographic of
children who have a disability so 150
million children worldwide we actually
think this is understated only because
countries like the US we're pretty good
at reporting but there's still some
countries where it is not acceptable to
have a child with a disability so we
actually think that that number is quite
higher but we'll go with the 150 million
and if you look at the world population
15 percent of individuals currently are
if you if you look at all those census
reports have or live with a disability
and being in the accessibility world
we know that is larger and so why I
always motivate that as researchers we
should be thinking about the spaces
because we are designing a technology
that we might eventually have to use and
so if we live long enough there there is
a stat that says if you live over the
age of seventy which of course we all
want to do on average you'll live eight
years with a disability and that could
be a visual impairment it could be a
kind of disability it could be a a motor
disability but it's some change in your
normative function it's something where
robotics and AI technology could really
engage and continue so that if you do
live in the home you have a quality of
life and so if you live in the home and
you can with this augmentation with
robotics and AI and so I always put on
my hat to say as researchers we should
all be working in the space because we
will eventually benefit from our own
work so that's just my little my little
cap on that and so if I look at children
specifically one of the nice things
about robots is that there is a
no-brainer we don't have to come in and
say oh can you interact with our systems
you know these since those are going to
help it's more of a what can I do and
there's also this over expectation
sometimes of what these systems can do
so it's actually a good problem to have
you don't have to try to convince your
say customer segment to adopt your
technology it's already there you bring
a robot in it's like oh what can it do
and I like to use it the other thing
about interacting and bringing robots is
that we then have to make sure that when
these robots are functioning they are
all menteng a human human interaction
and so when we think about this
interaction especially since children
are vulnerable they are highly liked
they can be influenced we have to make
sure that when we design robots and
redesign aook technologies for this
population that it has to be based on
human human interaction it can't be
based on well the humans are doing it
wrong I think this is just a better
thing even though sometimes that might
be the case the fact is is that we are
influencing their behaviors and so we
have to really be careful when we
introduce these AI systems that
influence decision-making capabilities
that it still matches some type of
normative function is still mapped to
something that everyone else accepts and
so as
researchers we sometimes make decisions
about what our AI systems can do it may
not necessarily be always optimal it may
not be necessarily efficient if you look
at all of the metrics with respect to
conversions and things like that but it
may be optimal with respect to the human
and so we are always very conscious of
that which also means that the system
works and so one of the couple of the
challenges that we have to deal with is
that every individual is different a lot
of times as researchers we think about
oh there's like the space line and
there's this distribution and there's
like this middle norm that everyone kind
of Falls and there's anomalies but the
fact is is like everyone's an anomaly
and so when you think about technology
about designing technology such that
every single individual is an anomaly
the decisions you make in terms of how
your system adapts is much different
versus saying we're going to design to
this norm that we think about and
everything else out to the extremes is
anomaly it's like no everyone is
actually out to the extremes and the
middle actually doesn't exist and so
they've shown some data that like that
middle that we all love actually doesn't
exist when you're interacting with
people because people are different
every individual has their different
style it might not be that time in the
morning maybe it changes in the evening
and things like that so that's one of
the challenges is when we're designing
these robots for doing therapy for
example how are they moving how can we
model that how can we figure out what
they're doing in that moment in time the
other thing is is that individuals even
adults so if you remember the session
that that was we heard in the morning
about you know our time how our
productivity goes down because of our
emails and things like that some of that
is focused on workload and switching
context we have really lost our ability
necessarily to pay attention for a very
long amount of time on one thing for
kids kids are actually designed and the
reason why is is that they're wired to
try to switch because they're learning
about the world and the things that are
going around them and cause and effects
and there's things that are so dynamic
and changing so constantly that they're
trying to bring this in and so for kids
they are designed to actually do the
switching like okay I'm focusing on one
thing I'm focusing on another
whereas adults we we actually learn how
to focus and pay attention as us that
are over the age of like 22 most of us
we have learned this I will tell you for
those faculty that are out there the new
generation they're not designed and
wired the same way in terms of paying
attention and so our robotic systems
have to function in the domain where a
kid is going to get bored very easily if
the robot isn't engaging a kid will turn
off and not focus and if a kid is not
paying attention to the content their
learning outcomes decrease their therapy
and movement outcomes decrease and so
our goal with these AI systems is to
ensure that we keep the child constantly
engaged changing our interaction
changing our behaviors so that we keep
the child one task and that's really
understanding that they're designed not
to stay on task and therefore we have to
engage them and maybe change the task to
do that and if we put that all together
we can create these systems and so this
is just a diagram of our entire AI
system where we have gamified therapy
both tablet based games as well as
virtual reality games where a child is
doing things everything from movement
trying to go across the the midline
all the way to turn taking if I'm doing
a behavioral therapy and so we use the
gamification to really engage the child
of course the therapists and clinicians
need to know that it's working they need
to have the metrics and so we establish
all these metrics and then of the robot
is there to engage and keep the child on
task changing the task itself if
necessary are just engaging in terms of
being socially interactive and so when
we put the system all together we can
show that our AI systems can influence
behavior can influence the decisions can
influence the movements of a child and
so our robots I was classically trained
as an engineer I never really thought
when I was going to school I'd have to
understand things like cognitive science
and neuroscience but there are reasons
why agents should have emotions there's
reasons why a chatbot that is socially
engaging has better customer engagement
and it's because we as
we are wired as social creatures our
communication style has aspects of
emotions and everything that we do and
so our robots they mimic emotions in
order to engage these kids and what we
can do is therefore we can show that
over a time period not only can the
robots engage these children keep them
on task but it influences their their
outcomes whether it's behavioural
whether it's motor whether it's
educational at the end and so we know
therefore that AI can be used for this
good and for this positive and we have
enough data that has been in the clinic
as well as the home setting and not in
the lab because we do our testing out in
the field in the wild to show that when
we put these AI systems in the real
world that children do learn children's
behavior changes and if we take and
remove the agent that some of those
learning outcomes actually stay so it's
not necessarily although if you look at
our chart it doesn't say as much as we'd
like but there is some influence and
there is some impact with the agent
there even when we move but one of the
other things that we've also seen is
that as we're designing these robots
because they're socially engaging
because they model these human human
interactions we also see that children
and adults are starting to trust and
engage the decision-making abilities of
these agents and so this is a little bit
of concern so this is one study that we
did where we had this engagement we
brought in these robots they engage with
individuals and then we also looked at
what is their interactions with the
human therapist and if you looked at the
outcomes the same ie their learning of
the task was the same where there was a
human where there was an AI but when we
asked and probed about things like well
what are your feelings about what is
your trust what is your engagement what
we found is is that with a agent a
robotic system they trusted the agent
better even though outcomes were the
same so if you looked at what they learn
it was the same but for the robot agent
there was an increased level of trust
there was an increased level of yes I
would use that robotic platform again I
trust the decision-making capabilities
of the robot platform even
the human was the expert in this case
was the therapist was the domain experts
in this case and so that started us
thinking about this aspect of trust and
what does that mean because as you know
AI is not perfect I mean any system
that's out there even if it's 99.9
percent there's that one chance where
your system is failing and if you think
about decision making capabilities and
you're thinking about domains where you
have high risk that even if it's 1% that
could be of concern if individuals are
trusting the decision-making
capabilities then we have an issue and
so we started poking at that and we
couldn't do in health care and kids
because remember kids are highly
influenced and so if we introduce things
like well what happens if the robot
intentionally makes mistakes we have a
vulnerable population that is not
allowed and so we thought about how can
we evaluate this aspect of trust and
over trust when we have some AI systems
and so there's one scenario and I'm
going to talk about the bad which is
this aspect of trust there's one
scenario that everyone is trained in
terms of behaviors and what it is is
evacuation so if the alarms went off
right now
think about what would you do you stand
up and if you're adults you'd actually
get up if your kids you hold hands you
stand up and you look for your exit and
you walk out this is actually a behavior
it doesn't matter you kind of learn you
get trained you look for your exit signs
and so there has been studies and what
we wanted to see is what would happen if
you had an agent that was introduced in
the scenario alarms went off and there
was an agent that was there and said hey
let come this way and what we did is we
intentionally did things like if you
look at for your exit signs
we took the robot and put it in a place
where it was counter to that it was also
counter to there's some studies that
have showed if there's no exercise
around people in terms of their
navigation behavior will go out the same
way they came in and so if there's no
exit signs it's like I came out that
door I came in so I will go out so
that's the behavior and so we wanted to
see what would happen if you had an
agent that would do that so we
introduced we invited participants to a
building they were coming to the
building they would follow this robot
and we
actually tried to remove this aspect of
social interaction because we wanted at
least the the physical in terms of being
engaging because we didn't want that to
influence the behavior and so you would
come in you follow the robot to a room
you would go in we had a big sign on the
door because we didn't want them to know
that the experiment was about to happen
and the big sign said you know please
close the door sit down read this
article about robot navigation it
answered the survey questions like you
know a lot of HRI folks do so they would
close the door they start reading and as
they were reading what we did is we
filled the building with smoke and this
is what you would see
so alarm goes off with you do you stand
up you're like Oh false alarm you walk
to the door you open it up and this is
what they see and so reactions are some
are oh my gosh there's smoke maybe it's
not a false alarm
let me find where the exit is and so you
kind of quickly move and we again
intentionally put the robot in a place
that if you can see the exit sign right
we intentionally put it where it wasn't
the exit sign and it wasn't where you
entered and what we want to see is first
pass what would you do and if you
followed the robot you would actually go
into this open area which is not again
outside and what happened was we we saw
some very strange behaviors our first
pass where there was no mistakes the AI
agent just led you it was a hundred
percent individuals would not go outside
the door would not go to the front door
they followed the robot and so we said
well maybe it's just because you know
they knew better or not and so we kept
pushing things in terms of mistakes and
introducing and what we found was that
when you have these aged then and we
poked a little bit afterwards in terms
of interviews and surveys about what
happened but the kinds of behaviors we
saw with this agent was actually as a
researcher was was baffling to ourselves
because we knew that there was this
aspect of overt rest but the level of
over trust was was actually quite
amazing so things that we have and you
can kind of see some highlights some was
that individuals would literally stay
with the robot and so again remember the
alarms are going off there was smoke you
were just in this room
individuals stay there was where we
increased the risk where there was
clearly you can see where the robot was
leading to you you may have you had to
physically do something and so we
thought well maybe because you're in
virtually walking individuals would move
furniture in order to go into these
places and again it baffled us about
these systems and if you peel back a lot
of the information about well why would
you follow why would you do this it made
a mistake what's going on something that
was well it's an intelligent system and
you know it must have information that I
don't have it must know something that I
don't know and the other thing was and
it says emergency robot so of course it
is an expert in this field right and we
laugh at this but this is the system
that individuals are interacting with
I'm going to a customer service agent
I'm going to a chat bot I'm going to a
therapist that's online it's a therapist
so it must know even though like my
intuition says that something's wrong
and so this actually worries us as
researchers and so we're seeing this in
a lot of our cases we're now working
with dementia patients and this is
something that we and that's why I said
it's bad we as researchers in this
domain we really have to think about as
we're deploying these technologies
individuals are going to trust what
they're doing even though we're like oh
but our accuracy is only 80% that 20%
individuals are not necessarily going to
feel and validated like I think it's
wrong they're going to trust it and so
this is actually a concerning and then I
want to go to given that our AI agents
might make mistakes and individuals are
gonna trust kind of the ugly and so
there's been a lot of news about this
aspect of ethics and and AI and things
like that and and we do know that
systems are out there and why I'm really
concerned about that is that kind of a
history is is when we started in this
space of interacting these robots with
children what we saw was in one of our
studies the outcomes were different for
I work with young kids they were
different for girls and boys and you
think like why is that like that
no sense and so as a researcher you have
to peel back and you're like okay
there's some bump here what's really
this and we were doing a study with
children with autism and the fact is if
more boys are diagnosed with autism and
so what happened was we looked and be
like oh all of our learning data about
behaviors and human human interactions
was based on clinicians interacting with
boys and so when we designed our entire
system based on this that was the data
set and in healthcare again children are
influenced and so we want the best kind
of learning outcomes the best kind of
therapy outcomes for that and so and I
always think and I'm a girl and this
happened right and so this is something
that we have to really be conscious of
and so we've looked at things like a
motion recognition because again we have
these socially interactive agents we use
a lot of emotions one is recognizing
children's emotions as well as
reciprocating and as you know most of
the system's out there of course they're
you know kids there's not a lot of kids
datasets out there if you go on the wild
and do all the scraping most times it's
going to be adults if you're older
there's also a bias but definitely kids
so there's not a lot of data set that's
out there for training these things are
out there and one of the things we know
with emotion recognition if you have the
data out there and you use people like
Mechanical Turk workers to label it
there's different biases that we have
and they've done this and they've looked
at this in in the social scientists
where I'm more likely to recognize my
own gender and my own race and so if we
think about the demographics of our
workers because I use Mechanical Turk as
well because they're there it also means
that our labeling is going to be
representative of what's out there and
we know that there's biases and of
course there's no Mechanical Turk
workers unless they're line that's like
under the age of 12 and so of course
even the labeling of any kids data sets
that are out there is going to have some
aspect to bias about I don't know if
that's a 5 year old or a 10 year old
I'll say 10 and that of course
introduces errors into my system when I
use that and of course like any good
researcher we kind of poke about poke it
and so we've done a bunch of different
analysis about what's out there
currently
what's commercially available with your
two kids and of course there's a lot of
happy and surprised kids out there right
like imagine and I'm a parent and I want
to post something on YouTube I'm not
necessarily going to post my kid crying
because I didn't give them that present
I'm gonna post happy kids right like
here's my kid and they're happy and so
most of these data sets as well as most
of the commercial applications that are
out there are really good at like happy
kids but if I'm in a therapy session my
kids are I need to understand my robot
needs to understand if I have a child
that's about to have a male time there
are expressions that are there that the
robot needs to understand and know I
can't learn it if my data set doesn't
represent that and so we're trying to
really fix that and dig that and so we
have some promising methodologies that
are part of that so some of it is
training out the bias how can we use
what's already out there because we as
researchers aren't going to create
something that like the world is going
to adopt but is there a way that we can
take what's already out there what's out
there in terms of API is commercially
available and put some type of filter
put some type of lens on it so that you
can still use whatever's out there but
put your lens I have a kid's lens can I
put a kid's lens on whatever's out there
and still use it for my application and
basically take out the buys and so we've
shown that with very little effort we
can basically remove bias based on our
target demographic so it's not this
general like we're gonna remove all bias
it's say I'm interested in an age bias
and therefore I can create a lens such
that I can use commercially available
systems that aren't trained on my age on
my kids but I can then use it so that I
can get the maximum benefit of that but
then have this isolation so it does work
for my systems and so can we we can
definitely do that and so I put the
publication as you know and you put your
publications up there so everyone can
reference and so the other thing is that
I do have some hope and so as we're
looking at this aspect of bias and and
things like that I think a lot of times
as a roboticist we do things like my
robots and there was no sound but my
robots
we use neutral voices right we actually
don't necessarily use words we use
sounds because we know that again
because there's this bias with respect
to definitely faces as well as voices if
I hear a certain type of voice my
interaction is going to be different and
so we also know that we can train this
out if we're conscious of these kind of
things we can do things differently so
we're thinking about decision making I'm
going to leave you there with this last
study we did one and this is why I know
this can work if I show this type of
robot again remember kids and I say you
know what's going on can you describe
most individuals will say oh kind of
range
oh it's happy it's dancing some might
say it's a little agitated I'm not sure
but kind of overall it's a excited
surprise you know kind of kind of thing
and if I just just asked about a robot
and emotions that's the response I get
now as soon as a researcher I do priming
which is I then define is okay this is a
girl robot or this is a boy robot or I
give it a color ie this is a black robot
what happens is people's perception
changes so without priming people treat
these agents as agents like they have
equal outcomes but as soon as a
researcher I give it either a gender or
a aspect of an age or a race we get more
comments of it looks a little angry I
don't think I would want to interact
with it again if I take away this aspect
of priming I get the same outcomes and
so I think again as researchers when
we're designing these AI systems and
we're deploying them out so many times
we we actually will you I mean I my
robots I call them XI right but I think
what happens is when we label these
things all those human-human interaction
biases come to the forefront of how we
interact and how we will make our
decisions and understand the decisions
that are provided to us and so I think
as a researcher we need to be a little
bit more careful as we're deploying the
systems about defining them with things
that we know we have biases and so my
claim is is i we have biases they're
going to be
existence until probably all of us died
but it really is our role to not make
our AI systems also inherit those and
there's certain things we can do by like
for example not calling them cheese or
he's are having some aspect of that and
so at the end the takeaway is I think if
you take nothing away from this except
that you know we over trust emergency
evacuation robots is that as researchers
we do have a responsibility in this
space we have a responsibility of really
consciously thinking about the things
that we do for AI influencing
individuals and making sure that we just
don't do certain things because at the
end of the day you know we're designing
technology for people right and it's not
necessarily designing it for our own
students we're designing for individuals
and so focusing on that will allow us to
really impact the world in a positive
way and so with that I am done and thank
you you have a few minutes for questions
oh thank you
a question I was wondering if you know
about any correlations between the trust
humans have to robots and the complexity
of the robot so believe it or not so
we've done some studies with like they
call it the Cookie Monster like these
blob monsters blob robots that that
exhibit emotions through movement and
what we find is is that those have more
of a simulation of pets the trust
actually goes high it goes higher but
they don't see them as intelligent so
there's this aspect of I trust it more I
think it's going to help me more but I
don't really think it's as intelligent
whereas with a humanoid it's a high
trust and high intelligence
thank you great talk
I'm saving savage from West Virginia
University and I'm also currently up
being how do you envision that we can
start communicating maybe to end users
the type of biases that certain robots
or certain intelligent agents have and
is it important to communicate those
biases that they might have I think it
is and and why I say that so we have a
study where we actually just got
accepted where if an individual if a
robot basically tells a user that it's
uncertain and we don't do like I'm 20
percent uncertain because we showed that
that doesn't work but if they say I'm a
little bit uncertain about my
representation what happens is
individuals will take the advice but
they won't take wrong advice but that's
being honest so the robots are honest
and we show that the outcomes are still
and so we have this basically Simon Says
task and so they have to basically win
the game and we when we are we provide
information that says I'm uncertain
about this but here's my answer
the outcomes end up being better even
when the robot is wrong so yeah being
honest
I think we're good 25 seconds all right
so I want to thank you and again
takeaways everyone should be working on
some aspect of accessibility to we
should really think about what we're
doing as researchers and our impact on
the world and not and being conscious of
our own biases when we're interacting
with these decision-making agents and
with that I'm down to zero thank you
thank you
[Applause]
our next speaker is John Kleinberg John
is an ACM Fellow and is also a member of
the National Academy of Sciences and his
research focuses our focuses at the
interaction between networks and
algorithms and their roles in our
society so it's my pleasure to welcome
John Kleinberg thank you thanks very
much okay so in this session on humans
and AI working together I want to talk
about some things that I've been looking
at with a number of colleagues and in
particular my PhD student my for ragu a
number of colleagues at Google with
sandal Melina --then a behavioral
scientist Zee odd obermeyer an MD and to
think about not just the question of on
a given task who's better at prediction
human or machine but to think we're
probably that the task of automation
broadly construed is not the task of
prediction on individual instances or
the solution to individual instances but
rather it's the broader question of how
to allocate effort within an entire
workflow and so we began thinking about
a simple model of the allocation of
effort as a broader optimization problem
and I want to start with that in in a
first domain and then I want to move on
to a second domain in a way more of a
toy domain but one which is highly
instrumented where I think you can ask a
lot of interesting questions so the
first domain and this is sort of for
concreteness to motivate the model
think about a canonical AI prediction
problem like diagnosis from medical
images right so I I see something
obtained from a medical imaging system
in this case it's a system to diagnose
diabetic retinopathy that was developed
and work with some of my first
colleagues and Google it would like to
estimate the severity of the diabetic
retinopathy and we we often see this and
we immediately jump to the question
which is better the human doctor or the
algorithm but we could think about the
overall process by which this diagnosis
takes place and by which many diagnoses
take place and ask given the performance
of the human in the performance of the
algorithm and their performance
characteristics how should this task
best be automated right which should be
done by humans which should be done by
by machines how does that work in a
larger workflow and we want to try
thinking about a very simple model that
would make that qualitative question
concrete so that we could that we could
think about it and ideally we could go
back to this very same data and
ultimately argue based on the model that
the optimal performance is achieved
neither through full automation nor
three-note through no use of algorithms
but through something in-between so how
would that work well that to work let's
think about a kind of automation problem
that someone in operations research or
an optimization might think about in the
absence of algorithms right so let's
think we're going to kind of tree
algorithm is we have a set of n
instances of some problem and I'll just
put up a small amount of notation here
it's not going to get much more notation
than this we have some small number of
instance of a problem in each one has a
ground truth answer and some loss
function that says how much cost is
there two different kinds of errors now
I can allocate human effort to that task
and I have to decide how much effort do
i allocate to each instance of the
problem and this is key to automation
that we don't tend to allocate effort
uniformly across all of the tasks that
we face even in this medical context
right concepts like seeking a second
opinion assigning a second or third
person to this particular case
revisiting this case because it seems
particularly tricky all of these are
ways in which we non uniformly allocate
effort and what we'll argue is that
that's actually key to how we might
think about the role of algorithms
as well so continuing with our notation
here let's imagine that if I assign K
units of human effort to tasks X I'll
get an answer H of X K and that incurs a
loss F of XK okay now it's important
that for two different instances of the
problem X and X Prime they might have
very different functional forms as a
function of effort some tasks might be
easy and so the first thing of effort
does a lot of good and the other ones
have very little marginal gain some
might be hard and reward increased
effort so the loss just keeps going down
down down as I some might be hard but
not benefit from extra effort it's just
gonna be hard no matter how many people
you assigned to it
so with that in mind I'd like to
effectively again in the absence of any
algorithm solve the following
optimization problem for each instance X
assign K X units of effort to do two
things respect the budget of effort I
have if I have a total effort budget of
B and to minimize the total loss right
so I'd like to minimize the sum of these
F functions the total loss subject to
the sum of all my effort allocations
adding up to must be all right what
happens when we add algorithms to the
picture now we have an additional choice
but let's stay within the same kind of
workflow right so the algorithm can also
provide an answer let's call it M of X
and incur a loss let's call it G of X so
now I'm not just trying to cite how to
allocate the human effort I'm also
trying to cite which subset of the
instances do I fully automate so that
the human never even sees it it's a form
of algorithm as triage in which there's
a set s that only the algorithm works on
and then the humans work on the other
instances possibly assisted by the
algorithm but that's in a sense implicit
in the model so now my new optimization
problem is the minimization is now over
sum of two terms the first term is the
loss incurred by the parts I fully
automate and the second term is the loss
on the parts that I allocate human
effort to again respecting the budget
okay so again just to recap that's
what's going on here first of all this
suggests a few things one it suggests
that we don't just need when we're
thinking about automation with
algorithms and algorithmic prediction
right we can't just say let's work as
hard as we count on getting mfx
we need to estimate two other quantities
in order to make sense of this
optimization problem this al
of effort one is we need a good estimate
of G of X the loss incurred by the
algorithm if the algorithm needs a good
assessment of its own likelihood of
error on a per instance basis it needs
to know it's doing well on some
instances worse than others second we
need to be able to aim the algorithm at
the human and assess human error right
because we need estimates of these
functions f of X comma K the algorithm
needs to understand to guide the
optimization problem what is the return
to assigning K units of effort on this
task X so all three of these things good
algorithmic predictions good self
assessment of its own error by the
algorithm and good assessment of human
error all naturally show up if we're if
we're going to optimally allocate these
things why do we expect that the correct
answer might not be full automation or
no automation well because if I think
about the balancing of those two terms
then something which might be going on
here is that first of all by automating
I free up human effort that I can then
double up on certain problems that the
algorithm is working with with the human
on right so maybe rather than having one
person on each instance I have two
people on some new instances or three
people that effort has been freed up by
automating some and secondly the
algorithm may actually be able to detect
that some instances are genuinely better
for the human right there may be some
the human will do better at and maybe
the algorithm can recognize that so we
tried some simple heuristics here going
back to this diabetic retinopathy data
set where these most recent trials that
have been done suggest that algorithms
are comparable to or in fact outperform
human doctors and essentially without
going into may in the details we can
sort all the instances by the algorithms
predicted gain right how much better
will it do than the human and it simply
triage them in that order right if I
would like to automate an alpha fraction
of all the instances then I sort all the
instances by the game from using the
algorithm instead of the human I
automate the first alpha fraction and
then I optimally assign the effort of
humans on the rest what happens when we
try that well I have two to two plots
here that sort of suggests the two
things that we thought might happen in
fact happen here on the left is a
histogram showing the algorithms
submit of the expected human error -
algorithmic ever so on the right hand
side you see these blue bars in the
histogram that's the positive part of
the axes that's where the algorithm
expects that it is outperforming the
human maybe more interesting ly on the
left you see these orange bars that is
where the algorithm expects that
actually the human is going to
outperform it on these instances where
it's making predictions right the orange
bars are lower reflecting the genuine
fact that the algorithms actually do
making lower error rates than the humans
but both sides of the histogram are
populated meaning there is actually
gains to partitioning these instances
correctly across places where the
algorithm is doing better or where the
human is doing better and secondly we
free up human effort to double up on
certain of these things so on the on the
right-hand panel we have plots of the
total aggregate error under different
proportions of cases that that we
automate right so over there on the
right if we automate everything we have
the performance of a very simple
workflow just full automation of all
instances over on the left is another
simple workflow which is we simply don't
automate anything we just assign human
effort and in between we have an
interior minimum on the error if we
automate some but not all then with the
residual human effort and with the
algorithms ability to recognize the
cases where the humans are going to
provide the most value in the process we
actually get an error rate that's lower
than either extreme so with optimal
triage neither full automation nor pure
human effort turns out to be the optimal
way to solve this optimization problem
even on these very well-studied
datasets where in aggregate algorithm
performance is higher and we see that
it's kind of striking because often you
know a sort of cursory gloss on some of
these situations is to say the algorithm
has now exceeded human performance let's
start thinking about the implications
for full automation but the point which
algorithm exceeds human performance is
not necessarily some sort of a
discontinuity it's not necessarily some
kind of a sharp break with the status
quo
it's rather simply a point in a
continuously morphing system in which we
want to be offloading more and more on
to the algorithm but still preserving
some out of human effort
achieve optimal performance so that was
one thing that we looked at in this very
concrete domain where we could look at
heterogeneity in the difficulty of
instances and how we automate but there
are many richer questions that would
that we can ask and for those we began
moving to other domains which as you
will see are less consequential than
medical diagnosis but which are really
beautifully instrumented and become
fascinating model systems in which to
ask these questions
so in particular here's a question that
I'd like to layer into all of this
so far we've thought about the instances
is varied and heterogeneous but we've
thought of the human beings as
essentially into interchangeable all the
humans are assumed to have the average
skill level the average ability to
diagnose but of course in the same way
the problem instances are heterogeneous
human experts are also heterogeneous in
their abilities in differential comfort
level with different kinds of situations
and so forth so we can sort of think of
the skill difficulty plane right if I
want to think about the probability of
error on a given instance by a given
expert right along one axis is the skill
of the person performing the task and on
the other ascus accesses the difficulty
of the instance the question is how does
the probability of error depend on these
two things and you can sort of
notionally imagine that that error
surface you know could look like the one
on the left which has a sharp tilt in
the skill direction right it really
rewards gains to skill and a very
gradual slope and difficulty right
increased difficulty doesn't really
affect performance but increased skill
has huge payoffs or maybe the error
surface is tilted like in the other
panel right sharply from front to back
which means it's a kind of problem where
small differences in difficulty
caused huge effects an error whereas
skill is sort of a second order term and
for any given domain we ought to be
asking the question what kind of surface
are we on if I'm trying to figure out
how do I reduce error is it more
critical these fine grained differences
in difficulty or is our differences in
skill how could we study this we would
need a domain that's highly instrumented
where we have all of this kind of
information where humans through a lot
of study have achieved some form of
mastery and yet where despite that
computers are that much better still so
we can actually
look and analyze even the best humans
and try to figure out where they're
doing well and where they're doing
poorly okay so we found such a domain
right a domain where a century of human
scholarly activity has essentially been
eviscerated by computers to the point
where humans effectively have nothing
left to offer and that's chess okay so
chess is something with an incredible
amount of skill being deployed but where
sometime around 2005 the 2005 to 2007
era truly was a kind of singularity in
chess in the sense that the last time a
human chess player in a recorded
tournament game beat a computer was
roughly 2005 okay computers are now so
the era of Kasparov and deep blue
fighting on equal terms is truly twenty
years ago if you pair up the best human
the best computer and ask them to play
as a team or even at a point now where
the best in the human you can do is just
listen to the computer and do what it
says okay now chess has long been a
model system right it's one of the few
things to have been called
metaphorically the drosophila of two
different domains John McCarthy called
it's awfully vey I Simon chase famously
called it the Drosophila of psychology
perhaps they should have said cognitive
psychology but it's because it really
provides us with data on a sequence of
cognitively difficult tasks where we
know the skill of the player
we know the the instance itself we can
try to set this difficulty we have
things like the time available to make
the decision and so the question is can
we use this to analyze human performance
along the dimensions right in this kind
of skilled difficulty plane given how
highly instrumented is right so this is
a typical instance that we'd be looking
at to chess players on the right is
actually magnus carlsen a 28 year old
Norwegian chess player who's believed to
be the best person ever to play chess in
human history and we're going to use the
algorithm to try characterize what are
called human blunders right in in chess
parlance okay now despite the fact the
computers are extremely good there is
the problem that in the end they're not
playing chess perfectly and so when a
human when a computer says that a human
has made a suboptimal moving given
situation in the end maybe that's you
know
Computers sub optimality maybe it's
almost a question of taste in a sense
which move was better so we wanted a
place where we could really diagnose
actual mistakes how do we do that and so
what we did was took advantage of
another development in computer chess
not the ones that we tend to see in
which chess engines have become so
strong but rather a more technical one
that for positions within most seven
pieces on the board chess has in fact
been solved right there's a bounded
number of ways you can arrange seven
pieces on a chess board it's very large
but with a few terabytes of storage you
can now play that part of chess by table
lookup right all positions are now
equally easy or hard for the computer it
just looks up what to do because it's
precomputed absolutely everything okay
and so that frame I took from a YouTube
video of Magnus Carlsen playing Peters
fiddler from Russia if you play it
forward another minute or two and you
read the YouTube comments where people
are following along what's going on you
got to this point in the game five
pieces left on the board Magnus's hand
is poised over the rook and you plug it
into your table base to see what you
know what should happen there are 18
legal moves for white nine of them win
at various depths and nine of them draw
exactly half the Meuse win and if you
play a forward a few more seconds you
see that Magnus grabs the rope pulls it
back one square to the square root G 2
and you look that up in the right-hand
column
rook from G 3G to draw all right Magnus
the best player ever to play chess in
human history has just thrown away the
win and is now we draw in a five piece
chess endgame right these situations are
cognitively difficult even for the best
people in the world and there's an
enormous amount of data right so what
with Ashton the understand and cental
Malayan we went to the free internet
chef server where people amateurs not
Magnus Carlsen necessarily but the
amateurs play online 200 million
recorded games right with the exact
moves the skill ratings of each player
via their chess rating the amount of
time taken all of these things okay we
took all instances with the most six
pieces because we wanted to sort of not
be at the outer limit of what was what
was feasible and we asked did this move
change the win-loss draw outcome of the
game in which case we'll classify it in
chess parlance as a blunder okay and so
can ask you know how does this depend on
skill how does it depend on difficulty
right these two axes that we wanted to
think about okay skill we can do a
simple sanity check so in chess players
have something called a rating the Hilo
system of ratings which is by all
agreements a relatively good one
dimensional heuristic rating that's also
been applied in in in other sports and
on the free internet chess server the
ratings you just for calibration range
roughly between one thousand two
thousand two thousand is a quite a
strong amateur one thousand is sort of
in elementary school class champion and
we also took a smaller amount of data
from actual world class games where the
range runs say from twenty three hundred
to twenty seven hundred they're about
fifty people in the world rated twenty
seven hundred and we see as you would
hope that the rate of blunders is going
down smoothly monotonically and
obviously the y-axis and the right hand
panel is much smaller than the y-axis
I'm left because these are incredibly
good players
how about difficulty that of course is
an interesting challenge yourself how
would you quantify the difficulty of a
position there's much that could be done
here and after trying a number of things
we actually for the purposes of this
analysis settled on something that is
simple but we don't have a much much
better substitute readily at hand we'll
call it the blunder potential what is
the probability of blundering namely
changing the minimax value of the game
changing the win-loss draw outcome if
you were to move at random right so in
that position from before where Magnus
blundered there were eighteen legal
moves nine of them preserved the win and
nine of them threw it away so that's a
blunder potential of nine eighteen sore
actually exactly one-half okay and what
we find is that if you plot this look at
this heat map on the right as the
blunder potential and position goes up
the probability that you make a blunder
also monotonically goes up which makes
sense although in fact some intuition
from things like complexity theory tells
us that the hardest instances of a
problem are generally not the ones with
a unique solution so you might have
imagined that the things with the
highest blunder potential the answer of
what to do would be self-evident there's
only one thing you can do you might see
it surely that is true in certain cases
but on average that's not the case
on average the blender rate just goes up
monotonically with the probability of
random blunders okay okay so we have
these two dimensions well with that in
mind we could try to formulate a
prediction problem right let's move into
the skill difficulty plane and ask what
does the error surface look like is it
tilted toward skill or is it tilted
toward difficulty so we tried a number
of variations on this one which threw in
a bunch of other features as well was to
say let's consider this as a prediction
problem given an instance of the problem
right that photo is an instance of the
problem right the position on the board
will also record the rating of the
player making the move the rating of the
opponent in case that matters the time
remaining in case that matters the
blunder potential that's our measure of
difficulty and a set of other attempt
here istic attempts at capturing
difficulty okay we took all of those and
we did some standard off-the-shelf
machine learning on this relatively low
dimensional problem just to see which
features were going to be the most
informative we found something
interesting that the algorithm came away
with a strong opinion on which way the
error surface was tilted in the skill
difficulty plane because if we used all
features we created an artificially
balanced data set in which half of the
instances were blunders and half weren't
if they use all features they got 75%
accuracy on this panels they said if
they used only blunders potential right
this one-dimensional feature that what
does the probably make a mistake if you
move a random you got 73 percent
accuracy right almost all the games to
prediction were in that single number
whereas if we looked at the rating of
the player and their opponent you got 54
percent accuracy so to the algorithm
looking at the error surface it
effectively is saying this thing you
call blunder potential that you're using
as project difficulty that's everything
it's fundamentally that and if you look
at this thing you call skill about which
you know many books have been written
well what is the basis of chess skill
that's a low order term in this
prediction problem and we go back to the
data and we realize it's actually you
can sort of see that so remember this is
the depends on skill let me stratify it
by the blunder potential right so the
blunder potential could be 0.1 or 0.2 or
0.3 right positions get harder and
harder let's look at this curve but only
over subsets of constant blunder
potential and here they are
and this kind of a visualization in a
sense of that metaphorical plane that I
had drawn earlier what you see is say in
the left-hand panel
these downward sloping curves the top
one is for plunder potential 0.9 the
next one is for 0.8 next ones 47 so
harder categories of positions are
higher up higher rate of blunders that
makes sense but notice how shallow those
curves are compared to how much gap
there is between them right so players
rated 1800 faced with a position of
plunder potential 0.9 or doing worse
then players we had 1200 these
elementary school class champions on
positions of floating potential 0.8 and
at point 8 these really good players
we're doing worse then the really weak
players at point 7 you just keep going
down right an extra point one in blunder
potential is leading to a higher rate of
error than 600 rating points which is an
enormous difference between chess
players in a way it's even more extreme
if I go over to the right-hand panel and
I read the y-axis I discovered that
players rated 2700 remember there are 50
of them in the world in a position of
blunder potential 0.8 are making
blunders at a rate of about 0.04 five
right about 4% rate I go back to the
left-hand panel I look at positions of
blunder potential point two relatively
easy ones
players are had 1200 or making errors at
a rate of about 0.03 right less right so
you would if your life depended on
someone not making an error you would
rather have the elementary school player
in a position of 0.2 difficulty point 2
then the one of the top 50 players in
the world in position of difficulty 0.8
again on randomly drawn positions every
position has its own idiosyncrasies now
this was surprising to us but the fact
that it's surprising to us is actually
its own field of study right it's known
in psychology as the fundamental
attribution error
the tendency to impute outcomes and
situations to the individual taking the
action and not to the context in which
they're acting right
you see somebody make a mistake mess
something up and you say boy they must
not be very good and you tend not to
think as much they must have been in a
very difficult situation where the task
was very challenging and that's exactly
in a sense our surprise is a reflection
of that right the difficulty is really
dumb here this is not to say the higher
rated players don't win chess games
because chess games are not decided by
the outcome of one move right it's an
accumulation of small advantages over 40
moves or 60 moves the better player in
aggregate is winning in that biased in
that biased walk but position by
position difficulties enormous factor I
just wanted to show you a few snapshots
of other things because we we do think
there's an incredibly rich data set to
get into some of the aspects of human
skill difficulty the nature of error you
could for example fix the exact position
right so with 200 million games you can
go into the simplest positions and they
have occurred literally thousands of
times in the data verbatim so I could
fix an exact position P and you'd say
let's say f sub P of R is the blunder
rate in that exact position for a player
of rating R so you'd expect that the
blunder rate would again slope downward
as the rating goes up and for most
positions that's true but you get some
strange positions right so the one on
the left is what you'd expect it says in
this exact position better players are
making fewer errors the one on the right
it goes up right this is what we call a
skill anomalous position we hadn't
expected they would necessarily exist in
the data but it's one where better
players are actually making more
mistakes right and the chessboard is
symmetric left to right the chessboard
symmetric between black pieces and white
pieces if you try all four symmetric
versions of that position they all slope
up right there's something really robust
in the in that in that position number
of other things we could put it all in
in T into e into a scatter plot it's
amazing how many orders of magnitude
difficulty spans in this domain right
ranging from positions where only one in
200 people make a mistake positions
where only one in 200 people get it
correctly right it's a it's a way sort
of automatically discover the very hard
instances from the data and some of
these instances and this will be the
point on which I leave before wrapping
up there are a number of theories as to
what's what's going on here and it's
going to surely be a composite of many
of them but one interesting one that
we've been seeing in a number of cases
is blunders arising from what you might
call misleading analogies so the
position in the upper left just the king
and a pawn versus a king has a blunder
rate of 0.7 55 in these several hundred
times its occurred okay
the correct move is to drop the King
straight back not drop it back
diagonally but if I translate that
position anywhere else on the board the
correct thing to do flips correctly is
to drop it back diagonally not straight
back and those positions all have much
lower blunder rate and it's just one
indication of some of the kinds of
challenges that that people face as they
as they applied problem-solving
heuristics to this so a number of
reflections surely it can't be the
difficulty is the only thing here
more broadly do we have a more
systematic way of trying to induce
knowledge of human heuristics and blind
spots from this incredibly rich source
of data but to come all the way back to
this top-level point in the end
automation via algorithms is not really
just going to be some sort of horse race
between algorithmic performance and
human performance and I think the talks
yesterday and today contain many many
many many many illustrations of that
point it's going to involve thinking
about the workflow the allocation of
human effort and I think a core
component of that is going to think is
going to be to think about what makes
individual instances easy or difficult
and how do they respond to greater or
lesser amounts of human skill as we
think about humans and AI collectively
working on solving these problems thanks
very much we have time for some
questions thank you nice talk John two
quick questions first there's also this
aspect of learning of humans you want to
pose them problems so that eventually
they'll become better players or better
yeah toss to us so so what's your sense
I mean you have to optimize the system
at the much longer term horizon than
just trying to solve a specific sequence
yeah it's a nice question right so how
do we present instances to people in any
domain right in chess in medicine in law
that are going to somehow are going to
help help people improve I think in what
we saw in in chess it was actually quite
thought-provoking
right this this third bullet
implications of empirical
we're teaching that if we think about
the canonical way to teach something
like chess end game play you would give
someone a book and it tax on Oh mais is
here's King and pawn versus King endings
here's with bishops here's with rooks
and so forth and it's sort of you engage
in introspection and you text on MySpace
it feels like when you look at the rate
at which people make blunders in the
vast swathes of easy positions that with
that kind of data you could easily say
let's spend time on this kind of
instance because it's very hard whereas
this instance will treat very lightly
because when you get to it you'll know
what to do we we know that from the data
and so I think that also can sort of
help us in the allocation of effort to
what instances to expose people to and I
think there are a lot of interesting
open questions here's a follow up there
also these this task that involves there
be multiple agents humans and aliens
that are working together so you cannot
allocate one fraction you know one task
to one person it's it's a team yes
what's your thinking about how do we
look at that kind of problems that you
cannot just divide one agent right now I
think that's interesting and and
actually in in the medical data there's
interesting question about aggregation
obviously and many people are giving
thought to this that if we say we've
freed up human effort so we can now have
multiple people look at this we could
have most people look independently and
do some kind of aggregation in an
arithmetic sense we'd have people look
collaboratively if an algorithm is
providing input into that process what's
the best way they can contribute
depending on on how the team is combined
its input are all various ting questions
hello John just a clarification question
in the chess when the expert player lose
a game do they do the Guinness rapid
decline this in their rating I was
wondering whether that has to do with
the way they behave and in the deception
literature they said the same thing when
the stakes are high you leak are a lot
more information on the stakes on
neutral yeah right so the in general
with with the online games and actually
my my co-author asked me understand has
done some varying work on how people
respond to the possibility of gaming
rating points or losing rating point II
you just think of the
the healer rating system which actually
was a very nice probablistic
generalization was done at Microsoft
Research through the trueskill system
which is used in Microsoft online games
it's essentially a kind of probabilistic
learning process to try figuring out the
person's true ability so if I beat
someone who's stronger than me I gain a
lot of rating points and they lose
points if I beat someone weaker than me
I gain a few and they lose a few and so
forth so each individual game has less
impact on the on the rating than the
sort of accumulation of a long session
of games and one thing Ashton has looked
at is people's behavior over the course
of a long session as they stake more or
fewer points of course in the data we
have on professionals playing
tournaments each game is obviously
extremely seriously and the stakes are
corresponding higher okay thank you John
we're movin move on to our next speaker
thanks very much our last for this
session is rich Khurana
rich is a principal researcher at MSR AI
and he's been doing a lot of work on
machine learning multitask learning
model compression and more recently on
in tribute ability and explain ability
for healthcare problems
great so thanks for being here and
thanks for inviting me to speak so I'm
going to talk about the ways in which
interprete Balma Xin learning
transparent machine learning can sort of
help turn us into detectives you know
good data scientists so that's what
we're going to go let me start first
with uh let me start first acknowledging
many of my co-authors who have worked on
this the last seven years
some of these are interns and grad
students some of them are collaborators
here at Microsoft and others are MDS at
hospitals and other people at other
universities so I won't name everybody
some of them are in the room here though
so let me start with a quote from
Sherlock Holmes this is the Hound of the
Baskervilles Sherlock Holmes says to dr.
Mortimer Derwin he's meeting them you
saw footprints and Mortimer says yes
footprints and home says a man's or a
woman's footprints - which Mortimer
pauses and replies mr. Holmes they were
the footprints of a gigantic hound so
what we're going to talk about is
footprints detection following the clues
and the relationship to data science and
the surprises that can happen right it
wasn't a man's or a woman's footprints
it turned out to be a hound in this case
a glowing hound
okay so as data scientists or detectives
of course the tools that we use are very
important now as many of you may know
there tends to be this trade-off in
machine learning where the most accurate
models models in the upper left here
things like boosted trees deep neural
Nets random forests attend unfortunately
to not be very interpretable so they're
gonna make it harder for us to be good
detectives because we're not gonna be
able to understand what they're doing
and the models in the bottom right of
this plot things like you know small
decision trees logistic linear
regression they're very nice and
interpretable they're easy for us to
understand unfortunately they're just
not so accurate on a lot of problems so
we'd really love to stick with the more
accurate models in the upper
left-hand corner here unfortunately
those things are as I said black boxes
we can't really understand what they're
doing and what we would love to do is
somehow maintain that accuracy but move
that black box to being some sort of
white box in the upper right hand corner
of this space and an interesting
question arises you know do any methods
actually exist that can have a
combination of high accuracy and high
interpretability it's possible that it's
actually just theoretically impossible
in general we've had some success over
the last seven eight years of putting
one algorithm up there it's not ideal
for all data sets but for many data sets
this is extremely competitive and it's
very interpretable and we've called this
generalized additive models with
pairwise interactions and I'll tell you
about that by the way for those of you
who saw the presentation I gave
yesterday there will only be overlap in
the very beginning of this presentation
and then we'll get on to new stuff so I
don't want to bore you with the same
things a second time so let's talk about
the space of model complexity at the top
we have very simple models it's a
function time I mean a wait times a
feature plus a wait times a feature beta
times X 1 plus beta 2 times X 2 that's
linear regression and then down at the
bottom we have full complexity models so
these are things which are just an
arbitrarily complex function of all the
features at the same time fortunately
there's something in between and this is
the space of what's known as additive
models where we have a function of a
feature plus another function of another
feature these are all functions of
single features at a time that's very
important and then they're combined with
an addition that's also important and
this is a very restricted model space
and fortunately it's going to turn out
that if done well you can get pretty
good accuracy out of this and it's going
to remain very intelligible so now we
can make that a little more complex the
first sum over I is the sum of all
functions of individual features that's
what I showed in the previous line but
then we can have the sum over all I J
for functions of pairs of features and
now we can have pairwise interactions in
the model that makes it a little less
restricted and and now more accurate and
we can go to three-way combinations of
features and do
do three-way interactions if we go far
enough though we get back to a full
complexity model that we can no longer
understand and in fact what we're going
to do is restrict ourselves to just
functions of main effects okay so it's
functions of individual features plus a
small number of functions of pairwise
interactions just the ones that are most
important now we didn't invent these
they were invented by statisticians down
at Stanford in the late 80s so these
have been around a long time and in fact
predate much of machine learning so so
Rob tips Ronnie and Trevor hasty are the
ones who invented these
however they were a little overly
conservative the way statisticians tend
to be when they fit these models and
because of that they tended to fit them
with very low complexity smooth
functions and that means they didn't get
very high accuracy out of them and
surprisingly it also means they didn't
get high intelligibility or
interpretability of them so our
contribution to the gams world is going
to be to fit these with modern machine
learning techniques and in the process
get very high accuracy out of them
accuracy that in fact most of most of us
thought was not possible and
surprisingly we're also going to get
very good intelligibility out of them by
improving their accuracy so now I'm
going to skip the technical details of
the algorithm I'd much rather show you
the kinds of things that this class of
models can help us do when we're trying
to do good data science detective work
so this is a data set from the late 80s
it's a pneumonia data set I'm just going
to use it to illustrate a few things and
then we'll go on to some other data sets
there's 46 features in this data set and
the model class is a function of a
feature plus a function of a features so
there's going to be 46 functions and
then we'll throw in 10 pairwise
interactions so there'll be 56 functions
all together and all of these are
learned at the same time with a complex
algorithm but I'll spare you the details
of that so here's what some of these
features look like so each feature each
main effect is essentially a graph so we
have a function of age of function of
asthma a function of your blood urea
nitrogen things like that and the way
you use these functions is you find your
age in the graph you read across the
cross the x-axis you find your age you
find where the Y value is for that age
and you write down that wide
you and maybe it's minus 0.23 for you or
for some patient and the way it works is
negative numbers lower your risk
these are log odds and positive numbers
increase your risks so you want to be as
negative as you can be because that
means you're a chance of dying from
pneumonia in this case is minimized so
what we do is we add up all of those
numbers and that gives us a score for
the patient remember there's 56 graphs
in this model so we get 56 numbers we
add them all up the more negative that
sum is the lower the risk the more
positive to some of the higher risk and
then we just do 1 over 1 plus e to the
minus score to convert this to in this
case we're predicting probability of
death so maybe the score that we got for
this patient when we added all the
numbers up was a minus 0.78 that's
actually a pretty large log odds you'd
rather be a minus 3 or a minus 4 but if
you calculate a probability out of that
you get about a 30% chance of dying
which is a very high probability of
death so you don't want to be a patient
who has this high of a score so now let
me show you let's zoom in on risk as a
function of age so this is just one of
the 56 graphs on the bottom we have a
histogram of the patient population that
we're seeing most patients are between
60 and 90 had to be an adult to be in
the data set so everybody is over 18 and
the top graph is what the model has
learned about risk your chance of dying
your log odds of dying as a function of
your age so let's quickly interpret that
graph so so down is low risk so so the
left side of the graph is the low risk
side of the graph that's for young
people and youth seems to you know end
at about 50 so everybody under 50 is
treated as being equally low risk and
young okay so it doesn't seem to
distinguish between people in their 20s
30s and 40s even though it could then
risk is going up slowly as you go
through your 50s and into your 60s and
then there's a sudden rise in risk
that's happening around 67 68
now risk is going up pretty rapidly as
you go through your 70s and into your
80s there's a surprising step function
increase in risk right at 85 which is a
very round number so it's it's
interesting and then the risk is kind of
flat as you go through your late 80s and
3 or 90
and then there's an even more surprising
drop in risk that's happening right at
around 100 101 so let's just talk about
a few of these features in the graph the
rise in risk at 67 68 that's almost
certainly due to retirement so this is a
data set from 1989 many people would
have retired at about that age or just
before that age you might have thought
retirement was good for you if you've
got pneumonia apparently retirement can
be bad for you many possible
explanations for that may be your daily
activity has changed your urgency to get
to care has changed your insurance
provider may have changed your doctor
may have changed you might have moved
and not even have a doctor where you've
moved to who knows why but somehow in
the aggregate all these factors
associated with retirement for the
average person have a net decrease in a
chance of survival as opposed to an
improvement in chance of survival so
your risk goes up now there's rise at 85
that's really a surprise there's nothing
in health care policy or insurance
policy that says we should treat 86
year-olds different than 84 year olds
and yet the model is actually pretty
sure that this is happening we've talked
to doctors and what doctors have told us
is that well you know back in 89 being
over 85 really puts you on those sort of
elderly side of of old in fact a lot of
medical data sets back then didn't even
record you know how old you were over 85
they just checked the sort of 85 plus
box and we think it's in effect kind of
like this you know
grandpa's 86 years old grandpa's very
elderly has a number of comorbidities
associated with being elderly because of
that grandpas now got pneumonia he's
very sick first round of antibiotics
hasn't really worked perhaps we should
let Grandpa pass like maybe that would
be the friendlier thing to do for
grandpa his time is coming soon anyway
maybe maybe we should let it happen now
and there was even a phrase that was
used for pneumonia back in the 80s and
earlier which was pneumonia is the old
man's best friend this this idea that it
was maybe a kinder gentler way for a
person to pass than a sort of long
wasting illness so so anyway that's our
explanation for what's happening at 85
when we see these step function things
at round numbers it's often that sort of
thing
this flatness through the 90s was also a
surprise we think that might be a sign
of what's known as successful agers
people who have taken pretty good care
of themselves physically they have good
genes and if they've made it this far
maybe at 95 they're not actually at any
higher risk of dying from pneumonia than
they were at 90 so so maybe that's what
the flatness is due to although we're
not sure about that the drop at 100
that's the biggest surprise right so so
in hundreds another very round number
and it's a very important round number
for humans you know you've become a
centenarian and centenarians back in 89
when this data was collected are pretty
rare things so we think what's happening
is the opposite of what's happening at
85 where we're giving a little less
aggressive treatment to somebody who's
crossed the threshold of 85 we think now
if you've crossed the threshold of being
over a hundred you're a centenarian
we're actually giving you even more
aggressive treatment as in pneumonia is
a very treatable illness you've made it
this far you've made it to a hundred
we're just not gonna let pneumonia be
the thing that takes you out we're gonna
we're if you need that third round of
antibiotics we're going to give it to
you we're going for the record
we're going to get you by this as best
we can so that you've got another year
perhaps so we think that's again a
social effect okay we've just spent some
time telling some stories about one of
the 56 graphs that's in this model well
one thing that's interesting is that
these graphs are the model this is not
some approximation of some other more
complex model this really is the model
now the stories of course are things
that we're looking at the model and then
we're the ones who are trying to play
detective and figure out what the models
do why the model is doing what it's
doing but we know exactly how the model
is going to make its predictions because
we can see these graphs the model it
turns out it's the most accurate model
we can train it's more accurate than any
other model anyone has ever trained on
this dataset so it turns out there's no
loss in using a model that's this
intelligible for this kind of problem so
you might as well use a model where you
can actually understand everything is
supposed to say some black box model
like a random forest or neural net where
you wouldn't understand these sorts of
things that are happening
the model moreover because the model is
these graphs we can actually edit the
model so I mean how many people think
that a person who's a hundred and five
is actually intrinsically lower risk
than a person who's not ninety-five
right that that doesn't make sense
biologically so one of the things we can
do is we can modify the model we can
redraw that part of the model make risco
slowly monotonically up perhaps past age
eighty or eighty five and if we do that
the model will do our bidding now we got
to be careful we're overruling the
statistics in the data the statistics
and the data really do suggest that
people over 100 or lower risk but we
don't think it's because they're
intrinsically biologically lower risk we
think it's because they've received
exceptional care once they break this
magic threshold of 100 so we've got to
decide whether this is appropriate or
not for us to overrule the statistics
now there are other things we could do
we could maybe fix this jump that
happens at 85 but I'm actually happy to
leave that in the model because that you
know our explanation for that is that
the patient's over 85 aren't getting as
aggressive treatment as the patients
under 85 so if I predict that they're
higher risk then maybe they'll get more
aggressive treatments so this this could
only be good for the patients is what
we're thinking by leaving that in the
model and then this effect that's
happening at retirement I obviously
can't change when people retire but what
we'd love to do next time we collect the
data is have a new variable which is the
retirement variable and then all this
complexity in the graph that's happening
in the the mid to upper 60s all of that
we'll move over to a new 57th graph
that'll be the retirement effect and
then we'll see a cleaner response of
risk as a function of intrinsic age with
the retirement effect now removed from
it so that's a kind of interesting thing
we're we're talking about increasing the
complexity of the model by adding a
feature to it by adding another graph to
it and yet that could make each of the
graphs that we have to look at easier to
understand and intrinsically more pure
so that's an interesting trade-off there
suppose for an insurance company and we
just want to make predictions we don't
want to intervene in anyone's care it
turns out the models already a good
model we don't necessarily have to fix
these things and in fact we might be
interested in the fact
people over 100 actually have a better
chance of surviving from pneumonia
presumably because they get such high
quality care
so as an insurance company we're already
happy with the original model it's
telling us about the statistics of the
way the world really works and we're not
planning to intervene in that world so
we're happy to use this model as it is
that's a really important lesson that as
data scientists as detectives we have to
take to heart which is that model
correctness data correctness the
appropriateness of using the model and
its predictions completely depends on
what we're going to do with those
predictions if we're going to intervene
in patient care then we may have to
correct some things in the model but if
we're just going to use the model to
make predictions about you know
financial decisions how much money to
keep in the bank then maybe we don't
want to edit the model this is the most
important lesson from the work is that
if you don't know exactly how the
predictions will be used you actually
cannot assess whether the model is good
or bad or whether you should edit the
model let me show you a few things the
model learned it learned that jumps at
around I mean there's jump set around
numbers all over the place in all of the
graphs I can't show you most of the
graphs they're almost always due to sort
of human effects policy effects social
decisions very rarely are there phase
changes in biology and physics so these
are almost always because of humans and
I'll show you a few more of these on
some other graphs for other problems the
model learns by the way that asthma is
good for you and it learns that heart
disease and chest pain are good for you
that if you've got pneumonia it's
actually good to be not only over a
hundred but it's good to have asthma
heart disease and chest pain let me show
you what the graphs for that look like
so remember if risk goes down that means
it's good for you it lowers your risk so
for the asthma graph if you don't have
asthma on the left your risk is near
zero it doesn't increase your risk very
much but if you do have asthma it lowers
your risk by about 0.2 which is
significant for chest pain it also
lowers your risk a little more than
point - if you've got chest pain and
then the biggest effect it turns out is
if you've got an obstructed airway which
you know doesn't sound good but it turns
out if you have an obstructed airway
your breathing sounds terrible and
because of that you'll pay a lot of
attention
and your doctors will pay a lot of
attention so it turns out all of these
things asthma heart disease and
obstructed airway there are all things
that cause you to get to care faster and
when you get to care to get
exceptionally high quality care because
you're considered to be seriously ill in
a way that it could actually put you at
higher risk from pneumonia so that's
what's happening is the model is
learning these confounding effects where
these variables which doctors clearly
tell us these are actually bad things
for pneumonia patients these things
actually look like statistically they're
good for you and that's because these
kinds of patients actually got to care
faster and then they got very high
quality care when they got there okay so
that's a fundamental problem as a data
scientist these are the kinds of things
you need to be able to see in your model
so that you can detect these sorts of
mistakes that your models are going to
make and and then fix them in with this
class of model you can fix these things
as well there's no way to collect the
data set that doesn't have these things
in it because healthcare is operating
for all of the individuals we're never
going to sort of withhold proper health
care from these individuals just to sort
of train a more accurate model so you
have to learn to live with these kinds
of things so just to jump forward I want
to point out that the model is rewarded
by predicting all these strange things
with extra low accuracy on the test set
and that's because the test set looks
just like the training set it has all
the same biases in it so if we edit the
model to correct these effects the
accuracy on the test set will go down
what we believe the accuracy of the
model in the real world will go up so
this highlights the large difference we
can see between laboratories sort of
practice and test sets which we use all
the time and machine learning to
evaluate things and the performance that
model might exhibit when when deployed
in the real world and how they can be
very very very different if you see a
model that looks like it has superhuman
performance
you really should question whether that
superhuman performance would translate
to deployment in the real world okay any
sufficiently complex model that's
accurate is going to learn these things
so so it's not just a particular
property of this model class in this
model class that you can see it and fix
these things you might think you could
fix these problems by removing some of
these features
unfortunately you can because of
correlation the model will learn these
same things from other correlated input
features the bias is actually coming
from the output signals not the inputs
all right let me show you a few things
and then we'll wrap up so obviously poor
tools make it hard to see things so this
is just a thought experiment imagine we
have a data set generated by these three
graphs so we just have three features
and imagine we fit it with a straight
line so that's my example of a poor tool
it's a linear model on data that's
obviously not linear so we might fit a
straight line to the first feature that
way to data from the first feature that
way data from the second feature this
way the third feature that way those are
pretty good fits right it's the best you
could probably do with a straight line
here's the interesting thing
if the features are correlated and if
there's any noise in the data it turns
out you may not learn those three
straight lines and in fact it's very
possible that you'll learn those three
straight lines and notice that the
effect for feature three actually has
the wrong slope and we see this all the
time this is one of the important
reasons for using a model that has
sufficient complexity that it can
accurately accurately capture the
phenomena that's happening in the data
if you use a model that's too simple it
turns out what it's telling you about
what it learn can actually be wrong and
signs can even be wrong so this is very
important okay but go tools really do
solve some of these problems so let me
just show you some fun things in graphs
so here's a graph of risk as a function
of blood urea nitrogen and what doctors
have told us is so fascinating about
this graph is that risk is very high
already at 40 whereas doctors tell us
they've all been taught that 50 a very
round number is the threshold at which
they should start treating patients so
doctor said this was interesting because
it told them they should probably start
treating patients at a lower level of
bun than they had been taught in in med
school but there's something even more
interesting happening here notice that
risk flattens off after 50 and then
notice it flattens off and even drops
after 100 right and fifty and a hundred
or very round numbers those are
treatment effects so what's happening is
the patients once they get to 50 are you
treatment the treatments very effective
and it actually causes their risk to
level off and once they get above 100
they give an even higher dose of the
treatment and that even in some cases
causes the risk to drop and you end up
with weird cases where patients who have
buns of 90 are actually at higher risk
than patients who have buns of 110 and
that's because the patients at 90 didn't
receive a strong a dose as the patients
received at 110
so so that's sort of interesting now
here's a question if we know there's
treatment effects in the model like this
should we or should we not edit the
model to correct for those treatment
effects turns out sometimes you should
and sometimes you shouldn't and that's
what I'm gonna leave you with is imagine
the following a blood pressure is
something that's very easy to measure
first thing you do when you get to any
doctors office is they measure blood
pressure you might even be measuring it
at home if we predict that your lower
high risk the odds are you're still
going to get your blood pressure checked
and if the doctor notes that you have
very high blood pressure you're gonna
receive treatment for it independent of
whether we predicted your high risk or
low risk so that means if we're seeing
an effect a treatment effect due to
blood pressure in our graphs maybe we
don't have to correct for it because the
intervention that we might do with our
prediction isn't going to affect whether
you get that treatment but suppose it's
like this we're only going to measure
your bun perhaps if we predicted your
high enough risk that you need the lab
test that means we won't know that your
bun is high if we didn't do the test so
that means our prediction can affect
whether you get the test therefore it
will affect whether we know your bun is
high therefore will affect whether you
get treated for your high bun or whether
you even get an extra high dose for your
high bun that means maybe if the model
is going to be used in such a way that
it's predictions could even intervene in
whether the test is ever done so that we
know you have blen high enough that you
need to receive a treatment then
probably we should correct the model so
that it does not predict that you're low
risk because you
receive the treatment because then that
would be circular we would predict the
patients who did receive the treatment
or low-risk then they wouldn't get the
test because their predicted to be low
risk then we would never know they had
high blood and they would never get it
and then they would be at higher risk
okay I'm just gonna stop there there's a
number of things like this where by
having good tools we're able to find all
sorts of defects that happen in the data
and that translates to defects in our
model and if we have good tools
intelligibility transparency into our
model we're able to find these effects
and then we can do what's going to be
won in some cases hard detective work to
understand why why the model learn that
why that's true in the statistics and
then possibly even harder work to try to
decide where should we be listening to a
human expert to rewrite part of the
model or where should we trust the
statistics that the model has learned
and let them stand intact so so this is
going to sort of create a necessary kind
of dialogue between experts and data
scientists and the model to try to
figure out what parts of the model
should remain unchanged hopefully most
of it and what other parts of the model
actually do need to be edited because of
the way the model is going to be used
and you might need to edit a model in
different ways for different intended
uses of exactly the same model thank you
thank you
[Applause]